hello if you want to know what Laura is
and how it helps us to fine-tune huge
language models such as gpt3 or llama
then this video is right for you Laura
is short for low rank adaptation and
comes in really handy because the cool
chatbots and language models that we
have been using such as GPT 3 Chachi PT
llama 2 Claude Falcon and so on are very
general purpose prompting them correctly
by asking the question right plus
showing them some examples in the input
only gets us so far and usually works
for domains that the model has already
seen in pre-training to really
specialize them for a task or to a
different domain to make them become a
banking chatbot and get financial skills
or a medical chatbot we want to
fine-tune them on our smaller data sets
such as I don't know transcripts of
videos from this channel if we want the
Llama model to impersonate Miss Coffee
Bean but when fine-tuning large language
models at least the open source ones
which we can download we quickly run
into a problem with their size highly
capable large language models are huge
because they contain tens to hundreds of
billions of parameters and during fine
tuning we need to load all of these
parameters in our GPU just like for
inference but we also need roughly
double the amount of space to save the
respective gradient for each parameter
just as a reminder of basic neural
network training we need the gradients
during back propagation to adapt the
weights according to the loss we
computed on instances from the new task
but with Laura we can fine tune large
models with only a fraction of the cost
Laura was introduced by this paper from
Microsoft and is surprisingly less
complicated than we expected and we'll
explain it it works like this with Laura
instead of modifying all these models
weights during fine tuning we freeze
them meaning that we leave them
unchanged and do not do anything to the
copy of the downloaded model instead we
add a separate set of Weights these
fine-tuned weights after an ideal Lora
training process represented differences
we need to add to the pre-trained
parameters to make the model perfect for
solving the fine tuning task but come on
what did we do we now have doubled the
number of parameters on our hard drive
yes but it is double the amount on our
hard drive and not on our GPU because on
our GPU when we load the fine-tuned
model for inference we add the
fine-tuned weights to the pre-trained
weights so we still have one set of
weights for inference in in our video
memory not two
the fine-tuned weights can be seen as
modifications to the original weights
which we can merge into the model if
needed okay so during inference we did
not increase the need of memory for our
GPU but how do we fine-tune the network
and adjust these additional difference
parameters and how can this be more
efficient since their number is the same
as the original number of parameters so
far right well this is the trick in
Laura it reduces the number of trainable
parameters but how well you maybe know
that a layer in a neural network is a
matrix multiplication to the input of
the layer plus the addition of a
so-called bias Vector followed by a
nonlinear operation the weights of the
network are the entries of the Matrix
which are the numbers we need to adjust
in training or fine tuning the larger
the numbers of parameters the larger the
matrices so gpt3 with 175 billion
parameters has much larger matrices than
gpt2 of only 1.5 billion parameters now
every Matrix has a rank which is a
number counting how many linearly
independent columns The Matrix has
linearly dependent means that we can get
that column by combining other columns
from The Matrix and if we remove
linearly dependent columns from The
Matrix we reduce the Matrix Dimension
but without losing information because
that information was already there since
we can get that linearly dependent
column from other columns in The Matrix
so Laura's idea is that we do not need
to optimize the full rank matrices that
have high Dimensions there's a lot of
numbers but rather we should do a low
rank decomposition by representing these
weights as the multiplication of two
matrices A and B we gain computational
efficiency because A and B together
contain less numbers than the original
weight Matrix in this example we have
six numbers instead of nine thus there
are less than numbers we need to tune
and the bigger the original waitmate
receives the higher the gains from doing
this decomposition to a low rank are the
effect of writing Delta W as a
multiplication of two smaller matrices A
and B is that we reduce the
dimensionality of the weight Matrix
through a thus we remove linearly
dependent columns and we regain the
original dimensionality through b again
the hyper parameter we need to choose is
the rank R because we do not know what
the intrinsic rank of the weight Matrix
is and we implicitly remove hopefully
linearly dependent columns by the a b
decomposition if we choose the rank too
low we reduce the dimensionality to
match and lose information because we
implicitly deleted linearly independent
columns
if we choose it to high we keep too many
parameters that are linearly dependent
and waste computation we initialize a
from a gaussian distribution and B with
0 and let back propagation figure out
what the right numbers in the matrices A
and B are according to our fine-tuning
objective so Laura in a nutshell means
that instead of tuning the large weight
Matrix Delta w we tune the smaller
matrices A and B told you that it's not
super complicated so after we've found
the fine-tuned weights by optimizing A
and B we should not forget to add them
to the original model to make inference
with the Lora fine-tuned model and we're
done but why choose Laura and not other
approaches that adapt models in a
parameter and compute efficient way one
common alternative to Laura is adding
so-called adapter layers in each
Transformer block during fine tuning we
only adapt these parameters of these
layers and leave the rest unchanged
since these adapter layers have very few
parameters even as few as one percent of
the Transformers feed forward layers it
means that during training it is very
compute efficient but the problem is
that large networks are usually
parallelized on Hardware while adapter
layers must be processed sequentially
this means that during inference
adapters introduce a noticeable latency
another common approach is prefix tuning
which is a continuous and automated
version of prompt engineering instead of
manually choosing the right words for
the inputs to prompt the model to give
the right answer prefix tuning bypasses
the word representation step we add
input vectors that do not stand for any
Awards in particular they are just
vectors that we initialize randomly and
we are calling them prefix we tune the
entries of these vectors with back
propagation until the model delivers the
correct answer compared to prompt
engineering where the vectors represent
words in prefix tuning then do not the
problem with prefix tuning is that it
occupies part of the sequence length and
reduces the size of the effective input
just like with prompting also prefix
tuning is difficult to optimize and the
number of trainable parameters is hard
to choose if you delete parameters the
performance can unexpectedly improve but
also vice versa there is not a clear law
so sure adapters or prefix tuning are
still very popular but since Lora came
out it has been only increasing in
popularity over the alternatives
and this was our little introduction to
Laura do not forget to hit the like
button if Laura is clearer to you now
after watching this video we hope to see
you next time so subscribe
bye
[Music]